He was the person, Richard Nixon once called the most dangerous man in America,
a symbol of counterculture who encouraged the country to turn on tune
in, drop out trippy stuff. For sure.
And that's how Timmo leery is largely remembered while he definitely was a
proponent of noting on shrooms and trip on psychedelic drugs,
leery was unique in that he gave a bit of professional credence to the idea that
opening your mind with L S D was a perfectly acceptable way of life and
self exploration.
At least he did it first often cited as a Harvard professor,
even though he wasn't leery is a figure almost as L is the drug
out trips.
He and his divots endured throughout the 1960s and 1970s.
He was so much more than a psychiatrist turned. Hi icon,
leading a life,
filled to the brim with experiments well outside of mainstream academia,
in addition to the establishments of a controversial community and an escape
from prison,
eventually Larry claims that his frequent use of hallucinogenic drugs gave him
the ability to,
among other things commune with his ancestral past enemy of the state
or harmless hippie. Well, you decide.
Larry was born on October the 22nd, 1920,
and it was a simple case of perfect timing.
It took a rather indirect Ruth through school to graduate from the university of
Alabama in 19 43, 7 years later,
he earned his doctor in psychology from the university of California, Berkeley,
which set him up nicely to have an established career.
By the time the counterculture movement of the 1960s was kicking off in earnest
before Larry ever became a figurehead for the drug culture of the 1960s,
he was shaped by the circumstances of his childhood and a young adult life,
a member of these so-called greatest generation to find by growing up during the
depression and being sent to the front lines of world war II,
Larry managed to Dodge,
both of the traumas that shaped the rest of his generation.
His father was a dentist until driven by alcoholism.
He abandoned his family in 1934 for life as a merchant Marine Larry's mother was
fiercely devoted to him and he was a handful.
His education was a journey that criscross schools in 1938.
He enrolled in the college of the holy cross,
which is where he got an education of a different kind.
He learns enough about life and religion to push him into giving up his
Catholicism.
His second semester there became less about learning and more about hitting the
bars, picking up girls in his newly just car and running poker games.
After a year under the steeple, Larry set his sight on west point.
We're drawing from holy cross after passing the west point entrance exam.
It wasn't long until he was court martialed for lying.
The whole thing was hued up. So as to not bring dishonor to the school,
but Larry was ostracized by his classmates and ultimately resigned from
there.
It was onto the university of Alabama where he was expelled after being court
spending the night in the women's dorm.
He ended up at the university of Illinois and was as unlikely as it sounds
drafted into the army. The details of his time as then enlisted man are,
are a little sketchy,
but we do know that he spent some time working at a rehabilitation clinic in
Pennsylvania and was perhaps unsurprisingly suspended.
He continued his training though.
Maring Maryanne Bush in 1944 and talking his way back into the university
of Alabama with the understanding that he would finish his degree of a
correspond London's courses. And he did from there,
he worked his way through a Washington state university master's degree and a
Berkeley doctorate. By the time it was the 1950s.
An important shift was happening in the field of psychology.
Psychoanalysis was huge driven by the need to find reason why people were
suffering from various mental illnesses from depression into antisocial
behavior. This was the postwar boom.
After all in America was riding high on a wave of victory and
prosperity.
But if Americans had served an instrumental role in defending the world from the
most terrible threat to Liberty that anyone had ever seen,
then why were so many people so unhappy?
This was that many mid-century psychologists were eager to solve.
Many began preaching that the answer was all in the person's head.
It was taught that they were faulty,
that there must be something wrong with them.
Those they were the ones failing to adapt to a changing world.
By the middle of the 1950s,
half of the country's hospital beds were occupied by patients who had a
diagnosis of mental illness. This was the fields that Lee entered at first.
He subscribed to all the typical ideas of the day.
Psychology was about normalization,
about curing someone by getting them to fit in better with what was deemed a
normal society.
But even then there were dissenting opinions that decried this idea is a sort of
coercion rather than a treatment.
And some of the details Larry's personal life helped guide his shifts away from
this mainstream. It was a rough decade for Larry in 1955,
his first wife committed suicide.
She took her life on Larry's 35th birthday,
not long after confronting him about an affair to which he reportedly told her
that your problem, Larry ended up marrying his mistres.
But that marriage soon ended after the police lease were called by a land lady
who had heard him hit up. He reconnected with his estranged father,
but that reunion was followed closely by his father's death. In 1956.
Then when a former male colleague was arrested after looking for illicit
liaisons in public men's room, Larry suffered a nervous breakdown,
an extreme reaction,
perhaps it was speculated that he and his married colleague had been involved in
an affair of their own.
Larry needed to get out of town for a while to escape all of the depressing
elements in his life. So he headed to Europe.
It was there that he met David McLeans McLeans who worked as the director at
Harvard center of personality research became Larry's new career opportunity,
just as important was his summer trip to Mexico,
where he tried mushrooms for the first time.
The result of these two coinciding events was the Harvard psychedelic project,
radical experiments, fully sanctioned by university executives.
Now it's important to note that leery wasn't the only academic interested in the
effects and possibilities found in LSD from 1953 to 1973,
there were a series of psychedelic programs and studies run by various
organizations across the United States. In fact,
it's estimate that the U us government spent somewhere around $4 million of
funding,
116 studies that would look very similar to Larry's most notorious experiments.
Some studies were completely respectable too,
looking at whether or not LSD ands mushrooms,
both of which were perfectly legal at the time could be used to manage things
like depression, schizophrenia, and the pain of terminal cancer.
Somewhere around 1,700 subjects participated.
And those are just in the studies that have been made public plenty of others.
Weren't public Bo as laudable,
including the CIA's attempts at using LSD as a truth serum during
interrogations. And this is important when Larry got into the field,
there was nothing illicit or contr about it acted.
Carrie grant had a psychiatrist who treated him with LSD to great success and
author Ken Casey credited his time as an LSD test subject for pushing him to
write one flew over the cookies. Nest, Larry simply tried. It,
liked it and wanted in Larry had noble aspirations for his work.
Not long after he first tried mushrooms. He read a artist.
Huxley's the doors of perception,
which was written under the influence of masculine Huxley was conveniently
lecturing at MIT.
And when the two met over lunch at the Harvard faculty club,
they came up with the idea that research into psychedelics would eventually lead
to a kinder gentler world, filled with peace prosperity,
and an increased sense of enhancement while that might not sound like a bad idea
at all, it quickly proved to be well, a really bad idea.
The problem with studying subjects on LSD is they're absolutely out of their
minds and it's very difficult to conduct thoroughly scientific research on
subjects tripping out of their minds.
So Le experiments, they were rather let ask them scientific,
take the Concord prison experiment that ran from 1961 to
1963 and involved administering psychotherapy to 32 prisoners in an attempt to
see if treatments with hallucinogens would reduce prisoner recidivism.
The idea was that Sila Sabin,
the active ingredient in shrooms would allow subjects to have an experience that
would teach them something about themselves or the world that they wouldn't have
learned with more mainstream therapies.
It was suggested that this could lead to more successful integration into
society.
Sessions were held in biweekly groups with four subjects and two researchers.
And after a series of prep sessions and devaluations drugs were administered for
a day long trip,
the group would discuss the experience and subjects would be reassessed.
According to leery the results showed promise after the majority of the subjects
were released,
leery initially reported that recidivism was well below the average exp acted
percentage.
Then in the 1964 follow up Larry founds that recidivism in his experimental
group had regressed to the norm in party said because his team hadn't actually
provided the post-release support. They had been planning still.
Larry found something to lean on the subjects that found themselves back in jail
were there because of less serious offenses.
Then they had originally been convicted of, he chalked that up to a win.
At the same time he was working with prison inmates.
There were plenty of other less than scientific experiments going on under the
guise of the Harvard psychedelic project.
They were even less formalized with many of the researchers simply opting to
conduct experiments on themselves. In other words, they,
he dropped a great deal of acid. Harvard.
Wasn't happy with the way things were going,
especially when news about rampant drug use broke out in the press.
It went all the way to the FDA who decided it was about time to start regulating
just how these drugs were used Larrys program.
It was shut down and his term as a lecturer,
wasn't renewed at the end of the 19 6 63 school yet while he was preparing for
his departure. One of his colleagues,
an assistant professor named Richard Albert had a break with Harvard that was a
bit more dramatic.
The media picked up the story that Albert was fired when he was found trading
LSD for sexual favors from undergrads,
the mainstream press painted Albert and lyrics too much for Harvard to handle.
And that's not kind of publicity that makes anyone look good. Larry,
on the other hand,
didn't actually leave Harvard because of the rampant drug use.
Officially speaking,
the college declined to invite him back because it abandoned his class.
Instead of teaching,
he'd had his secretary give his students a list of required reading while he
headed off to California.
Larry and APER drifted a bit after leaving Harvard,
heading to Mexico for a short lived attempt at promoting L S D as a way of
magnifying religious experiences, the Mexican government didn't appreciate it.
And had them shipped back to the states. Fortunately for Larry,
he had come to the attention of a rich stockbroker named Billy Hitchcock,
who just happens to own the 2,500 acre Hitchcock estate,
a few hours outside of New York city in Millbrook. But the behest of his sister,
Peggy, who also happened to be a former lover of Larry.
He extended an invitation and Millbrook became the center of Larry's work and
1960s drug culture.
In spite of assuring the locals that days experimenting with drugs were over.
It was soon made painfully clear that wasn't the case. Why painfully,
because any doubts about whether or not there was some serious drug use going
on,
there were extinguished when a high end convinced he could fly jumped out of a
second story window and broke his leg.
That particular incident came after another.
That illustrates just how crazy things got when a vial of liquid acid had
broken in a suitcase on their way back from Mexico. Well, that's valuable stuff,
not about to waste it a past his clothes around to let people lick off a high.
The shenanigans that residents and visitors got tu at Millbrook exist somewhere
between truth and legends,
but there was a goal Larry and Albert were trying to find a way to create a
roadmap for an LSD trip.
They wanted to find that place of perfect clarity and understanding and develop
a way for practitioners to get to that point on a regular basis.
In the beginning, they held workshops,
gave lectures and wrote almost as much as they tripped,
but it didn't take long for the FBI to come knocking on April the 17th,
1966 officers found 12 children and 29 adults,
but none of the drugs they were looking for only a bit of marijuana,
still roadblocks were set up.
And anyone who wanted to go into their freewheeling compound was strip search by
law enforcement. And with that, another dream was dead
In 1966,
Playboy ran an article with a rogue psychiatrist where they talked about what
had learned from taking LSD 25,
a substance touted us a hundred times strong than Theros that had eaten six
years prior. At the time he said it undergone 311 psychedelic sessions.
And he went on to talk about how the sessions had revitalized him,
adding that he believed a 15 year old would be precisely the right age to make
the most of an LSD experience.
It wasn't the only Ify proclamation he made either the so-called psychedelic
dropout.
Those who checked out of mainstream society to spend much of their time
tripping. Shouldn't be considered a problem. He set instead,
they should be laed for their devotion to discovering ancient wisdom.
He described a mainstream society as an air conditioned, an likened,
his LSD activists to history's greatest thinkers, to be fair.
Larry also called for special to be put in place around the use of LSD.
Why? Because a bad trip could go horribly wrong.
And they took experience to guide someone through the drug-induced haze.
In order to guide someone,
he believed a person should have to apply for a license,
which they would only get after study preparation and passing a series of
physical and psychological tests. He argued,
this was much more responsible than doing something like outlawing it all
together without a legitimate way of getting and using this substance.
When he defined as a form of energy,
rather than a narcotic or a type of medicine,
he thought the industry would become lawless and underground much like what
happened to alcohol during prohibition.
He also made some wild claims about what had discovered on his a hundred of
trips telling them that he had managed to move his consciousness into the pre
cellular level. What exactly is that? Well,
he described it as becoming one with the cosmic beat of the universe,
and he even claimed to be able to tap into his own DNA,
to relive the experiences that his ancestors had had generations ago.
He described particular people, the soar again and again,
scenes of chaos and crisis all laid bare by so-called ancient
energies.
When asked about the most important lesson he had learned on his trips,
he gave an insightful answer.
He said the only real issue when he come down to it,
evolutionary cosmic sense whether to make it with a member of the opposite sex
and to keep it going or not to everyone had to make a choice to have children
and detain imortality or as he put it step off the wheel.
And that's a big part of why we remember leery today and why he made such a
sweeping impact on the culture of his time. While experi,
before him focused on making LSD a psychological weapon,
Larry argued that it could lead to vast insights, not only into the self,
but into the cosmos and into parts of the world larger than any human
could ever imagine. Unaided, of course.
It's not surprising that law enforcement had Larry on their radar.
They'd already been arrested on federal drug charges in 1965 and was handed a 30
year sentence, but was still allowed to go free on appeal.
He was arrested again after the raid at Millbrook, then again in 1968,
it was that arrest that got Larry's wife,
Rosemary six month sentence while Larry was transferred to the California men's
colony prison.
And this is where the tale takes a turn worthy of one of his LSD sessions.
. Larry managed to escape from prison with the help of a militant activist group
called the weatherman.
The weatherman who became the weather underground when they went into hiding,
started out as part of the Empress runs students for a democratic society.
They're peaceful protests against the Vietnam war were getting little in the way
of results.
And some members splintered into the weathermen and turned more Ireland.
In October of 1969.
They kicked off the days of rage by marching through a Chicago shopping
district, armed with a lead pipes and a lot of anger. They later bombs.
The headquarters of the national guard had plans to bond other high profile
targets around the country. But in the meantime,
they gave Larry away out of jail.
Larry and his wife were smuggled out of the us and into Al JS,
where they stayed with the minister of defense for the black Panthers or Cleaver
Cleaver.
And Larry didn't see eye to eye on things particularly Larry's continued drug
use.
It was after all in Islamic country with a tendency to go hard on drug offenses.
So Cleaver essentially pushed Larry and Rosemary out of town. From there,
it was onto Switzerland where they hooked up with an arms dealer called Miha
haha. They made an agreement.
Haha would protect them as long as he was given 30% of the royalties from the
books that Larry planned to write and why you should never get involved with
high profile arms dealers. How Shar knew that the more books Larry wrote,
the more money he'd get and decided that his cash cow would be more productive
in a place where he had no distractions. And while that was jail,
how sharp turned him in and he spent a month in solitary confinement before
Rosemary was able to get him released. After that Rosemary left him.
It wasn't long though before he found someone new in Joanna Harko Smith Tao to
AOR. And from there he found something else. And that was heroin from there.
And his new lady departed for Austria,
where he lorded the country as a beacon of compassion and freedom.
They weren't nearly as fond of him though,
as he was of them 1963 Larry's son-in-law was in town and they decided
to head out and meet up with the hashish supplies of Afghanistan. Unfortunately,
for Larry, it was all set. He was handed over to law enforcement,
returned to Los Angeles and dropped into a Folsome prison cell.
Interestingly made him Charles Manson's new neighbor.
We can only imagine the conversations that happens there.
Larry never quite adopted a totally clean and entirely wholesome life,
but he did begin cooperating with the authorities.
He informs on old colleagues and his ex-wife Rosemary who had seemingly dropped
off the face of the earth after leaving him in Europe. He did some time in jail,
but was free. And in witness protection by 1976,
that didn't last long as he was soon hanging out at the Playboy mansion and
contributing to hu. He also found a new philosophy.
One that looked less to the past and more to the few when he was in prison,
he came up with a new theory, simple S spell like this,
which stands for space migration, increased intelligence life extension,
essentially leery outlined.
What he believed was the next necessary step for mankind. As,
as our ancient ancestors, once evolved to walk on lands, leery,
believed we needed to evolve,
to travel the stars without expanding our physical horizon.
He thought it was pointless to expand on mental ones.
It wasn't the only late 20th century technological advancement that he was
interested in either. He also tried his hand developing video games,
including one called minds mirror and another sadly unfinished game called neuro
mana mind movie that far into technology in gaming.
It wasn't short-lived either. And by the 1990s,
he had declared that the PC is the LSD of the 1990s.
This new philosophy was turn on boot up Jack in and strangely widespread
use of technology.
Computers and games took off in much the same way Larry had once hoped LSD would
in 1995, Larry was diagnosed with inoperable prostate cancer.
Initially he insist that he wanted to meet death on his own terms and gained.
He had plans to commit suicide and broadcast the act live on the internet.
Instead he passed peacefully in his sleep.
According to friends and family who are within his last words were why, why not?
Larry was cremated and his ashes have had a journey just as bizarre as the one
that took him through life. Part of his were given to actress, Susan Sarandon,
who has since talked about how she and a group of friends had taken the ashes to
the burning man festival,
where they added some to their beverages and dranked to him in a toast.
Another seven grams of his ashes were blasted into space and a cylinder that
contained the remains of several others, including star Trek, creator,
Jean Roddenberry,
Larry May not have seen the rest of the world take on the final frontier,
but it's fitting that he did.
So I really hope you found that video. Interesting. If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below.
Also don't forget to subscribe brand new videos just like this four times per
week. I, why not check out in the other channel I do called geographics.
If this channel is about people, that channel is about places.
There is a link below and as always, thank you for watching.